zubie the British rapper who sounds more
American than I do was recently on the
podcast of the Lotus Eaters with Carl
Benjamin and Calvin Robinson I've never
paid much attention to zubie even though
he seems like an interesting and
talented guy he's been defending Andrew
Tate for years now and that usually
makes me question a person's
intelligence or Integrity but I can't
really question Zubie's intelligence
because he's clearly very smart and it's
hard to question his Integrity because
he seems like a really good guy so I
don't know maybe he's just been fed a
bunch of terrible information people
aren't perfect but on the podcast of the
lotus eater zubie who's notoriously
optimistic was asked about how positive
he can be given the recent Trends in the
UK Edward lant says zubbi brings the
kind of positivity we need to get
through these next five years of Labor
he man well how positive are you feeling
after looking at the way things are
going if you don't know what's been
going on in the UK I'm not going to
explain it here just imagine a train
filled with circus clowns and explosives
flying off the rails and crashing into
an already burning dumpster fire that
was lit by mental patients outside an
asylum for the criminally
stupid dude um I left the country three
years ago yeah um and it was yeah it was
it was very Bittersweet it really was um
I didn't want to leave kind of on the
terms that I did yeah but this was this
was 2021 this was when um people like
myself who are or organic shall we say
um did not want to take a certain
something and you know we're being
massively threatened and saying there
might you know prevent people from
traveling and stop people then I was
like all right I guess I got to leave
now zubie was born in the UK his family
spent some time in Saudi Arabia when he
was young he graduated from Oxford
University but he decided to leave a few
years ago because he saw where things
were
heading off the
rails so yeah I love the UK in many ways
and I've got lots of people here I love
but the country is really on a on a bad
trajectory I know it gives me no Joy
saying that like I'm an optimist by
Nature I know um and I will say that I
don't think things are as bad as they
may look as for on social media um but
things are not trending in a positive in
a positive wayone the signs are good
always pay attention to the trajectory
if your country is worse this year than
it was last year and if it was worse
last year than it was the year before
and if it was worse the year before than
5 years ago and worse 5 years ago than
10 years ago where do you think it's
going going to be next year and the year
after and the year after and 20 years in
the
future PE people are very I spent a lot
of time in the US and Americans are very
very concerned about the us as is the
rest of the world but I think that maybe
just because of the size and scale and
wealth and variety of the nation they're
a bit more antifragile yeah um whereas
in the UK it's kind of like if crap goes
down it really goes down right there's
no Texas you can move to or Florida or
right it's the states it's like okay
California might get messed up but you
can bounce without leaving the whole
nation you've got 49 other options
whereas here it's kind of like Fair
Point the US is big enough and
politically and economically diverse
enough that if you don't like the trend
in one area you can move to another area
the UK is like that to some extent there
are better and worse areas but because
it's so much smaller the better areas
can be swallowed up much more rapid
ly now for an extremely important
question and an absolutely correct
answer how do you think things can turn
around do you want me to give you the
most honest answer
yeah return to Christ man
amen return to Christ in Tradition
people need the faith say what you want
about Christianity but for 2,000 years
of Christianity the trend was to keep
improving no matter what what problems
there were no matter what disagreements
or Wars there were people kept making
societies better at any point you could
look around and see all kinds of
troubles but 50 years later things would
be better 50 years after that things
would be better still genuine progress
was somehow built into the
system then in our lifetimes it became
super cool to turn away from Christian
ity everyone instantly went totally
insane and Western Civilization started
crumbling from
within people are here you know whether
they're consider themselves Christian or
not I saw you know Richard Dawkins a few
weeks ago um you know you saw that Viral
clip where he was complaining about the
you know churches being churches and
Cathedrals you know be some being turned
into mosques or being turned into
whatever and this and he just you know I
quite like Cathedrals and this it's like
Bro you've spent your entire career
he spent his entire career under the
delusion that if he could just convince
millions of people to turn away from
Christianity society would become more
rational more scientific more
virtuous how's that working out for
everyone you spent your entire career
like there's no vacuum yeah again
there's no power like it's something
something will replace this you're not
going to just like whip out people's
relig and they just believe in nothing
no they'll believe in the state they'll
believe in politics they'll believe in
leftism feminism whatever ISM or Schism
um but it's it's not going to be neutral
and I think more and more people are
starting to wake up to that but on the
deepest level I think that's what would
be needed yeah get rid of Christianity
and something will replace it contrary
to the delusions of the new atheists it
won't be science it will be an endless
array of ideological time bombs but
zubie has a question for Carl and Calvin
can I ask you guys both a question yeah
yeah of course and this is um May maybe
maybe you haven't thought about this
before and I'm not even trying to urge
you in either direction I'm just curious
as to what your line is what would what
would it take for you to leave the
UK how bad would it have to get for you
to be like you know what I'm taking
myself and my family and we're going to
go somewhere else how bad would it have
to be how bad has Great Britain become
that the question among British people
now is at what point do we consider the
entire nation a lost cause and just
leave we get two answers which are the
two main answers that could be given I
mean for me personally it would have to
be a direct threat to my children but
then I would probably send them
somewhere else because I'd want to stay
myself and try and fix the problem okay
Carl Benjamin will continue fighting for
Great Britain no matter what
he'll make sure his children are
someplace safe but whatever happens he's
not
leaving I haven't talked about it
publicly yet but I am going to leave
I'll talk about it properly on my Common
Sense Crusade at 3 p.m. but yes I am
going to leave the UK wow I love this
country but I don't feel safe here
anymore Calvin Robinson is already
leaving he no longer feels safe in his
own country and he means he doesn't even
feel safe from the
government in another part of the
discussion he says that when he got off
the plane after a trip not long ago he
was concerned that police were going to
arrest him at the airport for something
he might have said on social
media who wants to live in a country
where your own government puts a Target
on your
back I know there are lots of people who
would agree with Carl Benjamin here and
others would agree with Calvin Robinson
I say they're both right it just depends
on what your really after there are
people who need to fight for their
country no matter what happens and there
are people who need to say here's what I
want to accomplish in my life and I
don't think I can accomplish it here so
I'm
leaving that's what zubie
did but whether you're on team stay and
fight or on team get out while you can
there's one thing that anyone with a
drop of Common Sense can agree on
unless there's a massive Christian
Revival in Great
Britain Americans are going to have to
start making room for a lot more
pilgrims
[Music]